for him but somebody who had a really
great game
is now sitting with us one and maxine
vashila grav bouncing back the way
jeffrey did yesterday had a loss maxim
he must have been tough yesterday
getting good sleep this is exactly what
the doctor ordered though coming back
today
well i mean i stepped
you know
i'm not influenced too marginally by
losses i
know that i need to sleep well so
but of course yesterday was a very tough
game in linear played extremely well
i
made a mistake you know from my
uh
not remembering my files and um was
queen eight in your files
i mean like
you're insulting my coach by asking this
question
just to you know
checking just checking no insult
intended um
but anyway today was also very tough in
the beginning because darius was
blessing moves one after another
but i had this feeling that i had looked
at all of this and
you know i couldn't remember his moves
so like this queen h4 for instance came
as a surprise but uh at least i could
sort of remember my moves and uh
find over the board that you know
everything i was doing was sensible
especially this
90 to 95 things so it's the momentum of
the game because
suddenly the position gets easier to
play for me and you know for
for a while it was not the case knight
d2 let's bring that on the board we said
today is the knights tour because
jeffrey's night i've seen zombies you
saw that as well flew around the board
your knight uh was on the start of the
game on b1 look for a moment like it was
maybe headed back to b1 when you played
knight d2 of course it got to the c4
square you just comfortably soccer you
gave your life square bishop back gave
back to your lifespan bishop i should
say and also sacrificed the pawn what
tell us why you assess this so easily as
it would be good for you
well i knew it wouldn't be bad
for starters and you know the bishop and
basic suddenly like squares like like
cues the pawn on f4
turns out to be a weakness in the end
and
i got
great control over not only the e file
over the diagonal with the bishop
inevitably so that's why i thought uh
darya should have played dtx3
when he had the chance with the bishop
on c1 this i was almost certain let's go
back to that position you're saying uh
yeah sort of
here i mean or d3 d3 was also
i was also looking out quite seriously
just oh boss with the ideas to
enter my bishop because once i get this
bishop on d2 and i do threaten to take
on d4 it suddenly gets very tough
uh
maxine if i may he played a kind of a
counter-intuitive move here c7 takes b6
what was your intentions uh once he
takes d4
c takes d4 c5 yeah and now queen takes
f4
ah that simple
queen takes f4 okay because another
opponent i mean there has to be a reason
for ctxv6 right it was just an
extraordinary thing right here at this
exact moment i'm sure queen f4 is
advantage for you the computer has
suggested the move a4 and we just
give away our grand master title
you're laughing too thank goodness
you're laughing yeah
he's kind of moves
into
if you had looked at this we were going
to ask the security to want you
once again but uh a4 is a
very bad player's move or two grades
yeah exactly one of the two but now
things were definitely going your way
here you have taken the pawn on a7 which
is excellent i could take on g7 but uh
then knight takes c3 yes
and if hook geforce and my work is kind
of stuck on g4 like queen f6 will always
threaten h5 so
i should take with the pawn on c3 kim g7
context d4 contact d4 and of course i'm
better but i thought uh
you know it's much more difficult for
darius to play with
both my works coming to the seventh rank
and so on you made the right decision no
question about it yeah and i thought he
should play something like hook d6
rookie one h6 and get his book to g6 but
it is ugly
right
something like this what you're just
that uh this was
in your view the way he had to struggle
or queen f6 i mean something like that
right right um
but but of course it is pretty bad but
in the game um
well
it's a bit unlucky of course that this
uh end game is totally lost after i mean
after you follow this recontext of four
because
it could happen that you get like this
b5 pawn but you you don't because of the
background mate so right
so a big comeback nice for you you're
back in first place
up and down down and up i mean i don't
count comebacks when it is one four two
one five so i will come to come back if
i i'm in first place after one night
okay well i was going to try to project
a little bit you get a rest day
to play that will be nice
lots of things to do
um
maybe some tennis or so and
some rests you know
talking with my coach
having fun
with my
with my friends online
like
that i haven't seen for too long because
i've not been to friends for
for so long but uh
yeah
hanging out and uh preparing mentally to
be very focused for the second half all
right we'll let you get to that
preparation great great comeback game
but we know you have more in you
congratulations thank you